[Music]
okay good afternoon everyone thank you
for joining this session here and I
believe you must be exhausted
it's specifically after the fantastic
lunch you guys had and everywhere on the
park wherever you go and see and I just
heard there are some beers also in the
in the probably the garden side so a
couple of rules please open your
recliner and you can relax it down
because I think we will take you some
journey of Kronos and I think what we're
going to show you here is definitely you
know you know very high level
synopsis talking about Kronos what we
are I'm sure you guys know us but but we
we play into a niche area of the market
but I think would like to explain that
and then also talk about our journey in
the Google Cloud three years back and
when we chose Google so I think and I
appreciate in case you guys have any
question in the middle peal field free
to ask and you know come to the podium
and speak here because they're trying to
record every question and if you cannot
let me know I will try to repeat it for
you okay so some highlight about Kronos
we have been in the market for close to
41 years now massachusett based
organization close to we serve plus 40
million employees I know we were talking
about billions everything what we see in
Google's what they do and we have close
to 40 million and across all 100
countries represent 31 location across
Kronos and cater fortune 500 companies
leveraging Kronos and also our partners
who leverage Kronos we have a various
workforce management offering and human
capital offering which kind of touches
the every nimble area of focus
management from a timekeeping to to
human resources to labor analytics and
to you know the the scheduling area so
in short you know any area which touches
the labor productivity index
specifically from any vertical any
organization across the world you know
and and I know when I saw a lot of
registration
lot of customers who are here including
Google you know using Kronos into our
various offerings what we have so we
will talk about I think these are the
key areas what domain which Kronos
serves what what will talk about our
next-generation offering which we kind
of build on our 41 years experience and
the input from you guys from the
customers and I'm sure when I say you
guys I will see a lot of other people
coming in soon here so I would like to
give you some you know some analysis
here so we are not new in cloud we
started our cloud journey around 200
2006 we have today 24,000 customers in
our cloud which is on our one of our
legacy offering which is work for
central domain and 90% of all our
science deals are on cloud so I think
the experience of running in a cloud the
the the cloud SAS business I think
existing Kronos so that transformation
happened for us
long time back but I think the cloud
native way the next generation of cloud
which made me say you know the product
building purely cloud native nest we
started that journey almost four years
back and I think that is where the the
birth of dimension and I believe if you
have seen our CEO Aaron and speaking
about I think the core name project
Falcon which had a big story which I
don't want to cover here not who you
guys what we started so one of the you
know three and a half year four years
back one of the key goal our our CEO
said you know make Kronos out of the
business he was looking for a
next-generation SAS offering which is
the only cloud native which is purely
SAS but also thinking about the future
of workforce management keeping in view
customers what customers think about
Kronos we have loyal customers running
from Kronos from 25-30 years and if you
want to build the next generation SAS
offering what areas of interest what
areas of opportunities for customer for
us we would like to make into it so I
think on the verge of that you know
the birth of dimensions which is our
next generation Sachs offering which
meant life this year went ahead and I
think we have close to you know seventy
plus customers in during implementation
phase and we have close to six seven
customers already live well served
sitting on a Google Cloud doing it it's
almost for a year now so the basic of
dimension and I think I would like to
give you a very high level and I will
try to take you deep down in each area
just to give you some overview of that
birth of dimensions with respect to our
customers experience what customers look
for us so if you in a very simple way
understand the the customers for our
product are basically three three areas
of people there's a manager in an
organization who wants to make sure that
he can manage the labor productivity
level in terms of Roe string timekeeping
and there's a user itself where you know
all of us you know we use time and
attendance you want to punch it use
biometrics timesheets how can an
employee experience can change and then
I think the IT team itself those
organizations who are sitting in inside
and everything is going cloud native
they are channeling that how they can
integrate the entire back office system
and make it more effective that is the
big challenge actually you know everyone
wants you go cloud but the internal
cloud IT team still has some legacy
application so some people are far ahead
like Google they are the first one but
there are some people organization or
last soup you know dealing with you know
on-premise versus hybrid versus multi
cloud and I believe you guys heard that
loud and clear in all your sessions so
our journey will go into that part and
and keeping all these areas of interest
keeping our customers investment I think
we want to build the this reversionary
workforce management experience which we
call dimensions and and and and then I
think we will also talk about that how
partnering with Google what gave Chronos
and why dimensions carries a different
experience which we already have and how
we leverage our experience but working
with you as a customer we added some
features and for sure I think I'm not
going to talk something new about it but
I'm going to talk about the the
artificial intelligence the
machine learning and then also the cloud
platform how we are leveraging it from
Google and building this next generation
offering by enhancing the customer user
experience so I think we started this
project with the simple experience as I
said with managers with employees and
with the IT organization man I just want
to make sure that they have very less
time and they have a lot of team members
to you know to manage with their routine
tasks with your timekeeping schedules
and think about different vertical think
about you know Hospitality vertical
think about the retail vertical think
about you know the ID technical vertical
or public sectors large organization
enterprises when managers are just
working still on timesheets Proust ring
sheets the manual way how can we enhance
their experience and then the employees
I spoke about you know where employees
wants to you know want to make sure that
you know when they need time off and
they need their roast ring it's all
available to them and the amount of time
which is being wasted and in getting
those thing process when the manager
doesn't have a time how we can plan that
out and then IT and I think we thought
how can we innovate again these feature
that what how cool it would be that if a
manager you know he can drastically
reduce his time by automatically the
time keyed the she the zero strain the
labor level can be automatically done
for him how can we analyze that data
which exists for him and can be
predictive by giving him recommendations
how can we have an employee where when
he stammering for a time off can be
automatically approved but when we know
that what shift pattern he does and how
they're managing it out and then for
sure I think the the foundation
principle which I believe which Google
has been trying to teach us from last
two three days how can you leverage the
foundation principle of the API is the
foundation principle of the integrations
and the the data which you have by
creating a cluster computing framework
which can govern the responses for you
which can give an organization like IT
teams their integration services where
they can hook this with any back office
system without even thinking about it
which normally today we
a big project in our existing world and
we'll talk about these areas you know
I'm not trying to intentionally give a
high level but starting the areas of
opportunities and key and to us we look
into and for sure when you get into a
cloud native business the entire high
availability entire global deployment
entire support ability comes by default
with that so I will give you a simple
example take a very simple example we we
built a workforce advisor which
automatically detects an employee let's
his name is Michael his routine decision
that him if I am submitting I am Michael
and I'm submitting my timecard
that should automatic it approved why it
has to go to manager why manager should
waste this time approving it when the
when the in line algorithm and in line
policy also already mentioned that you
know that employee has dates has time
available and it could be approved so
how could you increase the productivity
entire organization which can talk into
the labor resource in Dec and talking to
millions and billions depending upon the
size of organization what you manage and
we are using these combination by using
the artificial intelligence and the
business rule which I believe a we have
from our experience of 41 years plus
working with you as a partner and then
leveraging the inline technology what we
are trying to leverage and build out
there's a very big difference when I
will come and talk about a very
high-level dimension architecture the
approach we want to use when we build
with Google that will differentiate a
little bit way the way people do it with
cloud native versus the way Chronos took
an approach then also I think we also
thought about one of the key is areas is
how you you know data is everywhere I
believe the the best part which Google
has done that how they can forecast and
display that data analytically to us you
know where you see fun facts you know
they're processing 300 billions of data
it exists but I think how people are
presenting that out is the game here so
in our business in a workforce
management business if you can forecast
and predict that I have labor
productivity available and I know what
are the areas of concern in one of the
section and I know
that if the timekeeping I know the
product of index is not going fine and
then your data can predict and give you
those forecasts ratio when you're trying
to plan out I think that that is what
you need and I think that is what the
new featuring forecasting solution we
added which predicts the user experience
we have tools available which will tell
you based on the customer their vertical
relocation how can you provide the index
which can give you the improvement
efficiencies oh for sure I think as I
said the cloud native brings some some
fundamental foundation principles so we
reform the entire UI for dimension where
you know where the world is changing
where nowadays an app drives the
behavior rather than you click on app
you know like Facebook LinkedIn or any
other model I mean if you see Google
consoles
I think the way they drive it so part of
our UI I think we totally reform the UI
where it is purely cloud native and it
has a wave where when you log in so
there are days when you want an
analytical data so we are trying to
bring the entire UI by bringing the
chart and tiles which displays your
analytic behavior which which are so
exhausting a responsive where any
location any device any way you use it
will it will give you that information
and all the information is available up
front for you rather than getting into
the app and driving it out an app will
drive it to you and telling you that
whether you have a time of request
whether or how many time off so you can
build your analytical index up front on
the UI itself which is I think pretty
cool because now you have a real time
engine which is running along with your
real time services and giving you all
that display and the software is
becoming more intuitive too and again
for sure as I said you know it comes
with the embedded analytics we are
trying to upfront bring those
information there which are configurable
where you can you know bring the amount
of data based on your organization bail
on your personas whether you are in a
manager whether you are an employee or
you in an IT organization you can hook
to it and and I think you don't need to
get into any data warehousing solution
any eight years everything is a friend
available in a real-time way so I think
those who understand Kronos domain think
about you know one of the examples where
you want to do the
you know understand the totalization
understand the reporting index
understand the integrations of your
payrolls working overs when you get into
more workforce management means
everything is available at your UI where
you can manage it out and then for sure
I think then I want to give you another
perspective we saw the manager we saw
the employees where employees can you
know decide what is the scheduled best
for me I just want to give a gift glance
here where think about one of the
employee like Howard would like to
understand which location he wants to
work on would like to understand what
shifts he cannot fall in case if if he
wants to make make a ship chain today in
the world everything is a very process
driven where you know the workflow goes
to the manager approval and if manager
is not available then whether it will
happen or not but in this case scenario
everything if as long as you have the
rules defined the advisor can give you
those recommendation an employee has an
ability to choose and pick based on the
rules and configuration define which can
happen automatically so I think the
power of leveraging the workforce
management system by a user experience
from an employee I think can be enhanced
and you can reduce your unwanted time
which which he is leveraging and waiting
for those approval and that could be
leveraged towards better product
available and I'm sure enhancing the
employee engagement too and we have we
have been working very key areas you
know leveraging the AI and the machine
learning and I will talk about it how we
are doing it in the example so again you
know picking one of the common example I
think nowadays people pick Tesla but I
thought of picking nest here because
that resonates with Google standing here
so like the way nest has changed the
market you know when you deploying as
everyone knows which it reads a pattern
understand you behavior and then I think
said the algorithm where it
automatically thermostat or the any
security system what you leverage it
learns art and I think this is similar
kind of a behavior or user experience we
want to bring into workforce management
we know the history we've been working
with you you've been using Kronos
products how can we do it differently
why we can learn from the
history based on the data and reasoning
provide recommendations like employee
time off row spring scheduling analytic
where a product is driving these
behaviors and the artificial
intelligence can you know easily solve
this problem which technically humans
can do and and I think we we you know so
example like you know I can work in
afternoon shift when when when someone
is not available you can automatically
see that and you cannot worry decide
which person is available who wants to
do and you can put your priorities and
and decide the shift pattern without any
managers being engaged to manage that
part trust me when you go into a
different vertical like manufacturing
which has like shift shops running and
at the manufacturing plant such thing is
a huge labor indicated problem and even
if you go to hospitality sector also
even if you go to you know like
hospitals you will find this so these
are key areas depending upon the domain
and the verticals you play in the
artificial intelligence is you know the
way we are trying to cover and the
Machine lowering we are trying to do is
is technically you know providing the
right forecast accuracy to the system
making sure that the algorithm what we
are projecting is per customer
perspective only so for example a
question can come in mind that when you
are trying to do the machine learning is
it per customer perspective or you're
aggregating the entire layer because
when you talk about artificial
intelligent machine learning is can be
an aggregation for everything or per
customer basis so we have specifically
build our algorithms focusing on per
customer layer where we can depict your
customer your vertical your behavior
patterns the way you use the system and
it can advise you based on that subject
you you are a manager employee and how
you can manage that out so your
decisions are smart and I think and and
and it will allow your manager to be a
manager rather than acting and doing
those services where he should not be
basing his time in and and if the clips
what you see is a real-time use case we
are kind of showing where you can see
the employee labor index depicting on
patterns for monthly layer of volumes
labor and a maintenance because these
are numbers people are money
the most expensive proposition in any
organization you can talk about to
technology infrastructure I think it is
a resource so I think the art of
managing resource with an intelligent
way I think that is what the job we
leverage by leveraging our experience
and working with the customers and then
for sure coming and leveraging the
technology which is provided so now we
call it as d5 because we have five
elements which define dimensions so for
sure's or ferrous services
I should be full if I say that so
dimension is a pure micro services SAS
based architecture where our platform
services are d5 area API integration so
seldomly we are we've been asked from a
customer that how can I use my data how
can i integrate my data with my third
party services and can I have a sequel
where I can run you know if you talk
about legacy ways of running the
software so we we thought you know why
don't we build an open API a platform
where we make customers data available
in the public API which every tenants
can consume in a secure way and and for
that I think we use one of the the key
element which Google provide those by
using LPG so we leveraged fpg as an
on-prem software and we build a solution
along with dimensions we provide
customers and an an ability to have
public API as where they can consume
their data whether it is a reporting
function it's an integration function or
it is a customized function which they
want to do so that level of data is
available so that they can get the data
out and hook it to any of the CRM system
and make their back of a system and IT
system more efficient the artificial
intelligence by building out our own
cluster computing framework by using
known technologies available we are
trying to seed individual customer data
playing through the algorithms by
understanding and creating the workforce
advisor mechanism to depicting those
behaviors for the customers whether it
is decision based or whether it is based
on the AI language of 100 commands of
human layer by ingesting that and
recommending those behavior
then we then we also and along with the
in-memory computing we are also
predicting the analytical layer so if
you are punching it here you have an
ability to have real-time and I'll take
the spray within the UI itself so those
days have gone when you're running an
ETL and I know I'm for Google in front
of sounds new but we still have legacy
software does that well you have a 12
was the vdl running and the data is
coming you have real-time analytics way
where you can do N and we leverage that
by leveraging the computing power
available from a Google when we use
their GCP platform so I think the
benefits here you know that it's an open
platform it's predictive it process
large volumes of data by leveraging GCP
compute platform available which
provides us it manages the adaptive
rules and suit interaction which people
will over algorithms and then also it
unifies the data access where the
information access is available we build
work for designer for you where you can
create your own business flow we accept
that information and as I said you know
this GUI platform from an apt API has
been power we call as an API gateway we
build the entire dimension architecture
very heavily built on one of the secret
principle of sauce which is throttling
and guard railings because when you
build a multi-lane in the architecture
you want to make sure that every
customer data is secure protected there
are no noisy neighbor configuration so
epic and important role for us we're not
only externally publishing the API is
including even internally we make sure
that the whole ecosystem talks my hat
ways so we can control that and then we
can also and if in case a customer
requires you know this a further
customization of API they are possible
where we can leverage the same process
of certification to launch that for them
oh and I think in a simple way you know
some modern cloud with the robust API
framework built on an artificial
intelligence for sure using the
blazing-fast in-memory compute which
comes from in-line computer platform
from Google I think one of the key areas
and I will talk about Google also
highlighting what we when we leverage
what one of the areas and reason we come
here
and then I think the flexible domain
model what we build build on a pure
Microsoft architecture where every
technology has a domain model which
allows us to fetch the data by levering
API then passing it out whether in a
public API way or in a business workflow
information available on the product
itself which is totally I would say a
big transformation from Kronos from what
was until 17 years 41 years in the
market from an on-prem to a hosted model
the pure SAS native cloud built model
and and and I think that is where I
think dimensions is our next
transformation business where we are now
I think one of the business objective we
want to make sure that consumer can have
it's a fantastic great experience for
you guys
you can work anywhere any device what
you want purely you are responsive you
can collaborate scheduling your
timekeeping for solid employees which is
duration ways project based or network
time base can be very well managed and
then we can meet any industry specific
requirement which we cater and I think
based on the experience what we have any
question I you know I'm sure you feel
free to ask any question what you want
but then I want to come to the important
part one of the key elements when we
chose Google and I will tell you I can I
used to say that - Veronica - Jason and
- Shane and other people when we started
Google I can write thesis on that
because when I chose Google three years
back the team everyone was asking about
why Google why not Amazon I would say I
think one of the reason when you when we
chose we were in a transformation phase
and we needed a partner who can tell us
that how can we see the bigger picture
rather than going back to our world of
hosting private cloud how you do the
business how a cloud native work is
looking in the model how they can work
and partner with us my understanding of
model and we are actually very I would
not say I think we are different because
now Google has so many customers I used
to say that that is kind of an old we
kind of a build a platform agnostic
architecture in today in Google we just
use the GCP layer within first general
services rest everything is a platform
agnostic model the way we have built and
I think I would say it's a kind of a use
case
well people who think that Google just
have containers you come and build
container no you should think like
Chronos as an enterprise who comes with
a pure private loud experience redesign
the platform with the next-generation
offering as a greenfield built GCP and
the native services from infrastructure
and wrote our own architecture by
leveraging the entire cloud nativeness
and I think that is where as an example
I believe we learned a lot Google and a
lot and we were in this journey from
last three years where I think we have
complemented each other and and today we
stand where I'll tell you like I could
say that we are live it's been one year
but we have been live three years I have
6,000 people using Google in Chronos we
have literally if I count internally
close to more than a million employees
in the system we have close to 4,000
5,000 tenant internally being leveraged
by engineering and our internal
organizations and then have ear we have
literally 80 80 customers in the
implementation close to six seven
customers live and I think every week
and every hour I will say there in the
progress will be assigning in so I think
the overall experience in terms of you
know I for sure I think for the for the
context it is the best fibreglass
network security perspective in terms of
cost to the business is great what I
would say I think it's a partnership
when we needed Google I got my I got
everyone available not like you have to
go to Diane Greene at the end of the day
I think it's the people and engineers of
work I think everyone was available from
an executive layer to the Google
technical layer and I believe they're
very smart guys when you talk to them
and one of the star is she's just
joining she's late when I excuse her so
and I think you know I we we are on this
transformation business and I think we
are still not done one of the every year
when we come here our eyes got open okay
we thought we are doing great we're in
the SAS first but when Google shows us
here is the next five years where you
will go
so we you know we we tighten again and
and focus on projects again where that
how can we improve the services and at
the end of the day it is for customers I
think what we have to learn from Google
that even though Coronas were small and
Google were big they gave us that level
of support to understand
and I think that's what we are trying to
learn that also customers you know like
be the customer customers consciousness
customer experience and their
opportunity drivers and then we should
partnered up by leveraging the
technology and build it out so to me I
think standing today here I could say
and very firmly and I feel proud you
know that tree is back the decision we
made and today where we are with Google
journey and I can tell you like three
years back I had ten couches I was
seeing today is everywhere you know it's
getting short of it so the experience
for Chronos I think overall from our
engineer we we we build our software
there and we built software in a very
different way by challenging even Google
at some time you know that how can you
leverage us infrastructure to build and
then we also have customers running
large customers running in the system
we're not only here I would tell you
customers running from international
location hosted in US with a fantastic
latencies fantastic response time so so
I think our experience has been great
and I think we are on the learning curve
by learning from our customer sitting
here and then also learning from Google
by getting more inputs so it has been a
fantastic journey I would like to thanks
all the Google but also all the
customers who has been patient and I was
giving us this opportunity because you
don't get an opportunity to redo a
software again and again it's a lifetime
opportunities so I'll pause I know we
finish we have time for questions I
would say requests if you can ask here
if you can't I don't know how to bother
you if you want to recline or you're
open I can take your questions so when
is this infrastructure going to be
available for smaller organizations like
from your workforce ready product this
is d5 is that right just start yeah yeah
is there a roadmap or plan for those of
those users using workforce ready
absolutely so part of this offering we
chose damage and in fact you know I
don't know whether we're are eager to
ask you this question because she's
asking me every time when ready is
coming to Google so just to repeat a
question so workforce ready is one of
our acquisition of what Foxwood is of an
another product which is fantastic which
is for our small medium industry scale
not hosted in Google but a SAS product
does pretty well business so part of the
transformation you know our approach was
that you know you have to understand an
enterprise company coming to public
cloud world three years back I can't
tell you how I have to convince my
executive to be there but I think they
accept it so we have a success path here
with dimensions building out in Google
by leveraging the platform agnostic
model and and it's already in our
pipelines we're soon will be leveraging
the same for ready for from a customer
perspective you know whether you use
Google or not what you see is the
product available but I think we are
already have work in progress and and
very soon you will see it will be
available there too from from our
perspective I think we don't want to get
into the info to cure business we want
to focus on our domain business and
enhance user experience and these guys
are spending billions of dollar let them
do it and give us that service so I
think we have a successful success per
dimension and we want to carry out with
others also so soon you should see it
when coming it's already on the pipeline
[Music]